hello we're here today with Professor
Joe Stiglitz
and he's got a new book freefall that
describes the way we got into the
current economic crisis critique some of
what's been done to deal with it and
lays out some of the bigger picture
remedies that we need to address in the
debates we need to have in our country
to move forward to a more stable economy
that works for more people so thank you
very much for the opportunity to share
your book with folks on c-span it's a
very interesting read and I wanted to
start out where the book starts out
which is sort of the path to this
disaster how we got into this um the
first section of the book it describes
it and it's a lot of things people are
kind of aware of self-interested
deregulation that the financial sector
pushed for the Fed not paying attention
to a bubble in fact as you describe
helping to create it but a thing you
write about I think most people haven't
thought as much about is basically the
issue of incentives you talk about CEO
pay and executive pay but it's more than
that tell us a little bit more of that
well let me first emphasize why it's so
important you know economists disagree
in almost everything but the one thing
that he agree on is incentives matter if
incentives don't matter we're out of a
job so it's a very natural way for for
economists to think about the world what
went wrong in part were incentives at
the individual level and at the
organizational level the level of the
bank the financial institutions the
banks always talk about the importance
of being sent to pay what we discovered
in the middle of the crisis was that was
a charade because they got high pay when
their performance was good they got high
pay when the performance was bad so it
was clear that that was partly partly a
charade but it was worse than that
because they were designed to
to encourage short-sighted behavior and
excessive risk-taking sure excited
behavior the sinks it was on an annual
basis not on long term five ten year not
in terms of how well workers were doing
or how well what the firm was doing and
a broader sangs creativity how it was
doing compared to other firms if the
stock market would go up they would do
well so it was very much sure excited
and designed to encourage excessive
risk-taking and those are some of this
now the structural incentives are
interesting about the short-term
risk-taking that's right and and but it
was a incentives not only the individual
of the organization so you have banks
that were too big to fail what does that
mean you're too big to fail it means
that if you gamble and you win you walk
off with the proceeds if you gamble and
lose the taxpayer picks up the tab so
what are you going to do and you have
that kind of asymmetry you're gonna
gamble with your money because you have
nothing new coos I call this ear socks
capitalism it's not real capitalism but
they call it a capitalism because you
socialize the losses you privatize the
gangs and the point I try to emphasize
is when you have that kind of capitalism
it's not efficient and it leads to the
kinds of problems that we have in fact
you know I joke with my students and
said if we hadn't had a crisis it would
have meant that all our theories about
incentives would have been destroyed so
the crisis actually vindicates what
we've been teaching but unfortunately a
lot of other people are suffering as a
result well and I have this vision as I
was reading the first half of the book
of Adam Smith and David Ricardo sort of
rolling in their graves because the way
it's not suppose it's not supposed to
work that you take the risk and you lose
and you're rewarded that that's not the
basic principle that we're supposed to
have in capitalism so I'm wondering what
you think the role of economists people
in your own profession particularly in
government policymaking position
was in helping to create those bad
incentives but also you described a lot
about how they missed seeing the bubble
building they helped create the bubble
Greenspan tell us a little bit about
that well as I try to analyze you know
who's to blame which of course has a
question everyone to know unfortunately
I have to say the economists come in for
some share other economists of course
but they they played a role in a number
of different ways there were some
economists that we're pointing out
markets don't always work that there are
problems of information particularly
important in financial markets there are
things called externalities where people
have that consequences their action
affects other people for which they are
not compensated pollution is an example
so that lakhs of market failures has
been called and we've under gotten a
much better understanding of those
market failures but unfortunately the
you won't say almost the predominant
view in economics forgot about all that
and they became almost a servant of
financial markets and others who wanted
who gain from a free-market ideology the
notion that markets were self-correcting
always work now we should have known
that that was absurd we had the Great
Depression markings didn't work you know
one out of four Americans were we're out
of a job and for a long time so we know
historically that markets often don't
work but they forgot all that they
talked about a new economy that somehow
we were different but the only thing
that was different is in some sense was
maybe our hubris that capitalism has had
these ups and downs since the beginning
with one exception that's really
interesting the fifty years after the
Great Depression where we did learn the
lesson a week
created regulations to try to restrict
this kind of bad behavior and they were
remarkably well not only in the United
States but around the world there was a
one period in which there were almost no
crises anywhere in the world once we
started stripping away the regulations
and didn't put in new regulations to
reflect the changing economy the new
derivatives and things like that once
that happened we started having prices
again 100 and more than 125 in the last
30 years so this is not a surprise
I was chief economist the World Bank and
I saw these crises move in one country
to another this is only you might say
the second crisis in the United States
we have the S&L crisis in 89 but this is
the biggest crisis in the world and and
therefore we feel that we know it this
time and our taxpayers are paying for it
whereas as taxpayers in other countries
but unfortunate second ah McCleary has
economists have a lot to blame in the
sense that they they forgot about these
important experiences and what economic
theory had explained when markets work
and unfortunately when they often don't
work well you it the book is very useful
in explaining what I start thinking to
serve the cauldrons in which the free
fall was brewing different sort of
problems in the economics profession the
big trend towards deregulation the bad
incentives but brought all together one
of the things I think that you make a
very compelling case for is that this
was a man-made disaster not a natural
disaster and this is really important
because I think of how many times many
of us myself watch on television and
economists come out and say this was the
hundred year storm this was a fluke of
nature but in fact you make a very
compelling case that actually it was a
creation of man very much shell is this
this wasn't something that happened to
the financial markets it was something
that the financial markets did to
themselves and to the rest of our
society
and you could see it brewing and you
could see the the errors and logic that
led to it I mean for instance and here
again to talk about the role of the
economics profession they put forth this
idea that markets were always efficient
and if they're always efficient you
couldn't have bubbles if you couldn't
have bubbles you didn't have to do
anything about deflating the bubbles so
Greenspan could feel comfortable as
saying oh there there may be a little
froth but nothing for us to do anything
about and went on to say if there's a
problem much better to fix it after the
fact
heeling say how much it was going to
cost and how long it would take defects
but you know there was a party going on
and the regulator's didn't want to be a
party pooper and particularly because
they couldn't believe that markets
couldn't take care of everything and
again it's partly a problem they weren't
going to have to pay for the cleanup
we were oh and you described the fallout
in the book and I'm actually going to
just look at some of the particular
statistics because when I read it the
way I felt about it and even more so
after the Massachusetts vote the the
details of the fallout from this
man-made disaster are like the footnotes
that describe the rage a lot of
Americans are in across this country red
and blue of different demographics 58
percent of working-age population is
currently employed which is the smallest
percentage since 1947 we all hear the
ten percent unemployment but when you
look at it from that perspective but
that's a stunning figure millions of
families have obviously lost the value
of their main assets you describe the
inequality of who's been hit because
with the real estate deflation it's for
most working people their house is their
big asset income inequality at a height
not seen since their robber baron age
the book is filled with some pretty
startling descriptions of the fallout
you describe that situation and what
came after as a major economic war
between Main Street and Wall Street and
here's the question
Wall Street keeps messing up on their
own measurements they're not doing well
but they keep winning in this war and
that gets to sort of what happened after
all of that damage was done by certain
players how's that come to pass well one
way of thinking about it is you know the
financial markets weren't very good in
doing their main task which is managing
risk and allocating capital but they
were very good at managing political
capital and they spent a lot of money
and they've gotten a high return they
first got a high return from
deregulation they made him a lot of
money they then got a very high return
in the bail house the the bailout terms
were very favorable the Congressional
Oversight Panel looked at for instance
when we were giving them money we got
back securities the securities that we
got back at the time they were issued
were worth about 67 cents on the dollar
so we got cheated maybe the people doing
this were former investment bankers if
they've been working for a private guy
they would have been fired but you know
the raised question who were they
working for but now they're getting a
dividend another dividend from those
investments they're successfully
resisting pressure to re-regulate them
not to go back to the old regulation
that we had 75 years ago the world's
changed but we need a regulatory
structure that's appropriate for the
21st century and in my mind that was
part of the real debate of what we
should be doing at that critical moment
were we going to try to go back to 2007
before the crisis financial system was
over bloated 40% of all corporate
profits were going to finance
credit card fees that were extracting as
much money from ordinary people as they
could you know modern technology would
allow for an efficient electronic
payment mechanism the cost just pennies
for transferring money from your bank
account to the merger when you go into
the store you have to charge one 1% 2%
3% for doing that
these old are reflections of the
failures of the 2007 regime that we
don't want to go back to we had a as I
say a bloated financial sector we had to
bring it down to size we forgot that
means to an end not in the end in itself
but when we brought it down to size we
should have asked the question what is
it we want from the financial sector
what part should be maybe some expanded
thanks for capital the kinds of firms
that finance Google and the other new
dynamic enterprises that have financed
the small and medium-sized enterprises
to create jobs all the job creation has
been an but what do we do we let a
hundred and forty of our smaller banks
go bankrupt this year but we poured in
money to the big banks whose focus has
not been on lending whose focus has been
on speculation they you know when when
they came out with the high returns
everybody was you looked at look where
were they making the money trading
trading it wasn't from lending and they
still aren't making money from lending
lending has been cutting back they've
got small business by the neck and and
it's getting worse getting worse because
a lot of small business lending is based
on collateral collateral is often real
estate what's happened to real estate
values come down so we're gonna be
facing even more difficulties going
forward but when we were pouring money
into the banks we didn't ask those
questions where we want in our society
our financial system to go
and the result of this is we've wound up
with a financial system more
concentrated we were talking before
about incentives we economist sometimes
called moral hazard the risk of the kind
of risk again gambling it's gotten worse
well one of the things I recall from the
book that that was very clever as you
talked about how we get too big to fail
or too big to resolve banks because of
too big to ignore campaign contributions
and if you look at this whole situation
of billions being poured into those
banks they've gotten bigger than ever as
a result of the response with Americans
having millions of Americans having lost
their households without any help you
you basically come to a conclusion from
your book that in some ways things been
made worse it was a bad situation but
that the way the response was done made
it worse than it had to be facing a bad
situation and one of the things that
struck me is you talked about the
failures of the Bush and Obama
administration will rank amongst the
most costly mistakes of any modern
democratic government at the time in
what ways did the responses make things
worse and what's still salvageable and
I'm talking about the initial responses
not the reregulate as we're gonna
discuss that but the original bailouts
and emergency measures well let me first
give a broad perspective you know that
the banks the financial system had
wasted money they put you know if we had
all this capital we could have spent it
to create jobs to create new enterprises
we didn't we put money into houses where
they shouldn't have been and for people
who couldn't afford them so that was the
initial mistake then we have the crash
well going forward the question is how
do we best use the resources that we
have there's no reason that we have to
under utilize resources we make some
mistakes now going forward correction go
forward and and use what resources you
have fully but what have we been doing
not using our resources fully that's why
one out of ten Americans are in the
unemployment but actually the word
number is much worse one out of five
Americans would like a full time job can
get one so you know one out of five
that's that's a serious problem and
you're looking some demographics like
yeah youth afro-american youth it's
almost one out of two so you know these
numbers are startling tonight horrifying
horrifying if we had done the right
thing we could have used this money to
help Americans stay in their homes
rather than the millions who've lost
their homes we could have used the money
to stimulate the economy to create the
jobs but what did we do we poured the
money into the banks when we did our
welfare reform in 1996 for the poor we
said if you're gonna get welfare you
have to do certain things you have to go
through training after when we put the
bank's on welfare we said no it would it
would be bad for the banks if we put any
conditions on the banks so what do we do
we said do whatever you want we trust
you
I mean with my money yeah we trust you
we trust you now look at that record
would you say we trust you so what do we
do we what did they do with our money
they did what their incentives said they
would do and it comes back to the theme
of incentives they paid out the money in
bonuses they paid out the money in
dividends and I in the book in the free
fall I try to explain why that was there
is it centers why it was so predictable
but of course if they were paying money
out it wasn't money that was going to be
lent to create new jobs it wasn't money
that was going to recapitalize the banks
to make them able to lend more in the
future now the interesting thing is that
we've over that period we are the
Congress is so you know people are so
angry that they won't give them more
money we are doing it indirectly
surreptitiously they can borrow money
from the Fed at a low interest rate lend
it on and a higher interest rate then
they're not even to government
no risk and book the difference is
profits so we are recapitalizing but in
a way that will diminish the growth of
our economy because it's not leading to
lending and we're giving them money
without any constraints so what it where
where what are they doing with money
they're asking where is the highest
return they're looking around the world
where's the highest return well where's
the highest growth emerging markets so
now we have a double problem Americans
are unhappy because they are not
creating jobs we're lending this week
being constrained but the emerging
markets aren't happy because we're about
to create a bubble there and so they've
managed to get everybody to to cause
problems to every economy around the
world so Brazil has said no thank you no
thank you we're gonna try to make sure
that you don't rush in with your hot
money to lead to a bubble we saw what a
bubble can do we don't want that thank
you well it's very interesting I hadn't
thought really about that as part of the
solution their solution that didn't work
being causing more pain because one of
the things that the book describes which
I think is very useful for folks in this
country to understand is the role of the
u.s. in exporting both our radical
deregulation model but also then the
crisis and the contagion worldwide and
you described some of the instruments
like the International Monetary Fund the
World Bank conditionalities that were
imposed on developing countries to
deregulate to liberalize their financial
sectors etc the World Trade Organization
was used in a similar way or UN
Commission report describes the problems
with that so now we have those
institutions and those rules imposed and
then we have a worldwide crisis as a
result what is the worldwide response
that's needed as far as trying because
we've exported a crisis and it came from
us what is the u.s. role what is the
global role in dealing with the global
nature of this crisis well let me first
talk a little bit about the global
consequences as you said
we exported our deregulation philosophy
we also exported our toxic mortgages and
in a sense that we hadn't exported so
many of our toxic mortgages about 40% of
them the downturn in the United States
would have been worse
but we made we exported our problems and
we've now created a global crisis this
crisis has a very clear made in USA
label now one of the consequences of
that is been that it is undermined you
might say our credibility our role of
leadership because people used to turn
to the United States and they would say
with we ought to imitate American
institutions American policies you knew
what you were doing is what they said
they don't think that anymore and that
and the fact that Asia is growing
emerging markets are growing much faster
than we are is really leading to a new
you might say you economic geopolitical
balance and you see that in the
forcefulness with which the some of the
emerging markets are just responding and
global negotiations there they're much
more reluctant to to listen to the
preaching of the United States you know
United States Secretary of Treasury
would go to China and say yeah wag their
fingers and say you ought to liberalize
your financial markets like we did and
they had a robust debate in those
countries they they said no thank you
now they say much more loudly no thank
you because we were worried now we see
how worried we should have been what's
an interesting disconnect because I've
noticed for instance with the g20
summits you have now a global call for
re-regulation we're going to shift a
little bit back after this to the u.s.
Rhee regulation context but at the same
time you have the
National Monetary Fund's sort of the
arsonist being in charge of putting out
the fire as far as the instruments
perhaps for some kind of a global
mechanism in the crisis you have at the
World Trade Organization the United
States pushing for more financial
deregulation those rules already as
you've identified have to be reversed
the existing WTO rules that lock in
deregulation instead they're pushing for
more so there seems to be this perverse
notion of we need to reregulate but
there still are these global
institutions like you call fur then you
mentioned the need for a global
institution to manage a global economy
and the sad news I thought of as someone
who knows WTO ISM professor Stiglitz
there is one it's the WTO and it says no
regulation and the same at the IMF so
how do you see the dynamic of
internationally the given the shift in
the u.s. role which has its upsides
given as you call it market
fundamentalism didn't work what we were
exporting how do you see in this new
dynamic that some new rules for a global
economy are actually created well one of
the good things of the fallout from the
crisis was the recognition first of all
that the g8 was outdated
you couldn't have global problems be
addressed by a small club how could you
talk about global warming when the
biggest polluter isn't at the table how
could you talk about global trade
imbalances when China is not at the
table so moving from the g8 to the g20
was a step in the right direction the g8
being the club of the US the European
countries and the g20 now adding in
China Brazil India just for listeners
that's right there's still 172 countries
not represented and the g20 was a
self-selected Club no political
legitimacy no sub-saharan African
country other than South Africa they're
the developing countries basically
unrepresented so real deficiencies in
the structure but the other thing that
was good about the g20 was that it
became a place where the leaders got
together and unfortunately in the way
the globe
governings too often works is eggs
delegated to particular ministries
particular cabinet positions so at the
WTO you have the trade ministers at the
IMF you have the central bank governors
and the finance ministers the Secretary
of Treasury now what I saw when I was in
government and song when I was chief
economist the World Bank that quite
often those ministries have very little
to do with the national interest those
ministries start reflecting special
interest so the US Trade Representative
and trade ministries in other countries
get captured by particular special
interests the finance ministries
Treasury reflects Wall Street and the
similar financial institutions and each
of the countries so that's how you could
have the leaders saying we want we need
more regulation we're going to prevent a
recurrence and at the WTO they're saying
we have to push the agenda of
deregulation even though we've had the
biggest crisis in the last 75 years
caused by deregulation and even though
the spread of it around the world was
facilitated by capital market and
financial market liberalization this is
a special interest agenda and I think no
in in a sense this this dissonance has
brought home the extent of capture oh
these ministries and the difference
between what is in the national interest
and what is going on in these particular
international agencies and that is going
to make a perfect segue because we have
to take a short break for coming back to
talk about the difference between the
Bush and Obama administration approaches
to regulation and also what can be done
going forward
afterwards and several other c-span
programs are available for download as
podcasts more with joseph stiglitz and
lori wallach in a moment did you know
you can view book TV programs online go
to book TV org type the name of the
author book or subject into the search
area in the upper left hand corner of
the page select the watch link now you
can view the entire program you might
also explore the recently on book TV box
or the featured programs box to find and
view recent and featured programs
afterwards with Joseph Stiglitz and lori
wallach continues thank you for staying
with us and we are gonna go back to our
discussion with Professor Joe Stiglitz
and his new book freefall were just
about to discuss the difference between
the bush and the Obama administration
approach to the crisis so in the book
you talked about something I think a lot
of people don't realize that some of the
top personnel basically didn't change
you talk about Obama campaigning on
change you can believe in but with
respect to his economic team and to some
degree the approach it was more like
rearranging the deck chairs on the
Titanic what are the big differences
between Bush and Obama to the extent
that there are in their economic policy
but particularly in addressing the
crisis and what lessons you take about
the continuity of the personnel well I
think there was a clear decision to want
maintain continuity of the personnel and
partly continuity of the policies
because they didn't want to they were
afraid of destabilizing the markets you
know the markets use this notion of fear
all the time and they said if you don't
do this they held I had a pointing a gun
at the
Congress thing said if you don't give us
blank check for seven hundred billion
dollars capitalism will fall apart and
so that you sphere all all the time and
so they said you have to have continuity
and Obama bought into that set notion
now there were some very big differences
even within that because what they did
Obama Bush did not want to do any
anything about stimulating the economy a
big big difference Bush did not want to
do anything about mortgages and pouring
money down the into the banks was like
massive blood transfusion to a patient
suffering from internal bleeding and not
doing anything about the underlying
cause of the mortgages so in in that
sense those were two very big
differences the problem was the stimulus
was not big enough not well enough
designed if the continuity was and third
of it was a tax cut and the tax cut was
what Bush had done and it failed and
predictably economists explain why when
you have this overhang of debt the
uncertainty you're gonna save a lot of
it mean to stimulate the economy you
have to spend on the area of the
mortgages things were worse because a
fundamental problem was that the bubble
had broken now the problem was that the
banks the regulator's didn't want to
believe that they had done such a bad
job they didn't want to believe that
there was this bubble they wanted to
believe that the high prices were the
true prices and we were just in a
momentary momentary moment of irrational
pessimism and if we could just boy up
the spirits we say the right things talk
about green shoots everything would
recover overnight acting like it was
fact like it was the reality of course
was we had been in a dream world and the
reality was this new low level of prices
and that meant but one out of four
American homes were underwater they owe
more money than the value of their homes
that would mean millions of Americans
were going to lose the value of their
homes to deal with that problem you had
to write down the value of the mortgage
in one way or another reform a
bankruptcy there were lots of ways you
could have done it but you had to do it
they didn't do anything about that
problem the result is that in 2010 we
expect somewhere between two and a half
and three and a half million mortgage
foreclosures more than in 2009 and 2008
so it's not like the problems getting
better in some ways it's getting worse
some some have been restructured but
even the restructuring has raised
problems because a lot of the
restructurings have added new fees and
with the new fees right people are more
in debt the bank can record the profits
from the fees the fact that they're more
in debt shows up at a problem further
down the line were more of them may go
into foreclosure but that's the problem
that we'll have to deal with the years
down the line so on these two key issues
it was really they did something much
better than than Bush I mean you can't
compare the two but they did it wasn't
what we should have been done well
that's very interesting because that the
other observation you had that thought
was very interesting is that in how
Obama responded to the crisis in for
instance buying the argument about
stability and maintaining both a lot of
the same personnel and the same policies
you note that he is conservative in the
sense of conserving the system and
relative to how he campaigned is a
transformational figure that he quote
hadn't offered an alternative view of
capitalism but their sort of goal was to
muddle through and in part to throw
money into the existing system to shore
it up where do you think that takes us
well obviously it's taking us to where
we are now where the economy hasn't
recovered in the way that it should have
our national debt is much larger than it
would have been have we done the right
thing but you know when you talk about
you know conservative or what is in the
American tradition
there was one aspect of that that that I
found particularly disturbing and that
is when they were pouring money into the
banks rather than going with the usual
rules of capitalism firms often wind up
owing more than they can pay they go
into bankruptcy resolved and you get
resolved and you go into bankruptcy you
convert the shareholders lose everything
the bondholders become the new
shareholders in the case of banks we
have a very similar process what we do
we call it conservatorship what you do
is you shareholders lose everything the
pot holders become the new shareholders
and because government has insured the
depositors sometimes it has to put more
money in and sometimes it have puts up
so much money and that it becomes the
effective owner and then it reprieve
Atty zé's excels it back that's the
American Way but was so interesting is
that this whole process got captured by
the banks and they said oh that's the
kind of thing they do in Sweden and
these other countries but it's not the
American Way but it was the American Way
we did it in continental Illinois we've
done it over and over and over again we
have law saying that that's what you're
supposed to do we suspended the rules of
capitalism to give more money to the
bankers but not only to the banks but to
the bankers the bondholders and the
shareholders so in that sense again we
made things worse going forward because
we change the incentives because it
meant that they didn't have money at
risk government was standing there ready
to bail out the bondholders and the
shareholders and if that's the case
there's no market discipline so they
were undermining the market in the name
of the market that's a I mean that
observation is actually one of the most
perversely interesting ones and when you
think of moving forward
you you closed the final chapter talking
about how it often takes a near-death
experience for a person to be basically
forced to reevaluate their goals values
and priorities so here we've had
something close to a near-death
experience or as close as I want in my
lifetime thank you very much of the of
the economy yet there do seem to be a
sizable number of individuals finance
ears
some of them who've cycled into
government not only here but in
international agencies in other
countries pundits some economists some
scholars who still seem hooked on these
presumptions I've pretty much been
factually count approved and keep
touting the same the market
self-correcting the and I'm wondering
what is it gonna take if this didn't do
it to get folks to look at the
fundamentals which in the second half of
the book is what you're calling for well
that's right I think there's a way of
explaining this which is to remember how
well some people were doing before the
crisis in 2007 most Americans were not
doing that well median income adjusted
for inflation that is the people right
in the middle their income in 2007 was
lower than in 1999 but a few people were
doing very well including a lot of
people in the banks and a lot of other
people in our society but it was
relatively few well these people would
like to go back to that kind of a world
so they have an incentive to try to say
you know nothing big has happened it was
something that happened to us another
way of thinking about it and fixing with
your discussion of what how we approach
the problem you know the Plumbing's been
clogged it's a stuffed and what do you
do then you clump you call a plumber
which plumber do you call well you call
the plumber it'll put in the pipes
because he's the one who knows where all
the problems are he created the problems
but if you call him that same plumber to
unplug the
clogged pipes you're not going to get a
retro redesign of the plumbing system
he's going to say thank you very much
just send you a big bill for the
services and you're going to be angry
because you're gonna say you should have
you shouldn't have done you should have
had a better plumbing system in the
first place and it's gonna start flowing
again but the profits are going to go up
and the risk is still going to go onto
the rest of us exactly design exactly so
the the thing that I think is really
important for us is to have a vision of
not only what kind of a financial system
we want but also what kind of a society
what kind of an economic system we want
and remember the finance is a means to
an end not an end in itself and that's
even true with the economy the economy
is a means to its part a very essential
part but you know if our planet doesn't
survive because of problems of pollution
or global warming it's not going to do a
lot of good to know that we had a high
GDP so we we really have to assess where
we're going and and see are we getting
where we're going where we want to go
one of my concerns about what was
happening in the years before the crisis
was that not just did we miss allocate
our scarce physical capital or money and
went to the wrong place but also our
human capital you know as a teacher was
something that I felt very very
intensely because I would see some of
best most talented students being lured
into finance and in another era these
would have gone some of them would have
become doctors or some of the mood it
would have become researchers and
discovered a new laser or new new
transistors things would have
transformed our society made our well
you know increased societal well-being
people would have gone off to do work
and development helping poor people
but the the attractions of the megabucks
um well a straight word so many such a
large fraction of our most talented
people and I think that's an unbalanced
Society the the the final chapters of
the book talk about the connection
between the financial system and the
underlying economic system and then
envisioning what you want as a society
and making the economic system to
deliver on that before we get to that I
want to just go back to the domestic
part of re-regulating the financial
system because in the book you described
there were two phases there is the
immediate oh my god moment with the
bailouts and you describe very
interestingly the use of the of the
Lehman collapse to sort of create an
almost terror of oh my god the world
will end you must just do this now
after that subsided Congress started
working on in certain of the federal
regulators started working on reregulate
actually making changes to how
securities banking insurance would be
operated so as to try and deal with some
of the structural issues change the
incentives figure out where the risk was
how has that been going do you think you
you said the test would be if what's on
the table were adopted would it prevent
what just happened from happening again
how are they doing pretty badly pretty
badly let me just give you one example
the major change in regulatory structure
is to give the Fed more power but the
Fed was they were the ones who were
responsible they didn't use all the
powers they had to prevent the bubble
they were the ones who said we can't
have enough lay debt they helped well
not only that not only did they pump it
up in that way but they didn't that they
could have done something above putting
regulations on down payments other
instruments one of their arguments was
we only have one instrument interest
rates that way you make those points in
the book yeah so so they were
responsible so here you have the agency
that caused the problem or at least as a
large bear
responsibilities and you say we're gonna
solve that problem by giving it more
power without changing any of the
fundamental structures without changing
the fact that in the New York Fed it's
basically owned by the banks it was the
administration's plan or Congress's
planner both actually what's so
interesting this was the
administration's plan and the house plan
the Senate says this doesn't make any
sense and the Senate said we have to
create a new systemic regulator because
the the the Fed clearly didn't do its
job but even in the house there is great
deal of skepticism about the Fed for
another reason we live in a Democratic
Society in one element of a Democratic
Society is transparency you've written
about that and and the Fed is not very
transparent and it was particularly not
transparent in what it did in the crisis
Bloomberg went had to sue to get some
information critical information that it
taught was should be in the public
domain it won the suit and what did the
Fed do did it disclose information no it
appealed it says we are not subject to
the Freedom of Information Act which is
one of the basic laws of our democracy
to make sure that citizens can know what
the people who are supposed to be
working for them are doing we understand
why now they didn't I mean III yeah the
AIG bailout with the money going to
Goldman Sachs you know I wouldn't want
to disclose that either but and you know
making statements like we had to do it
the French said it was you know it would
violation of the law if we didn't pay
them a hundred cents and the dollar
meanwhile in France they were settling
these for less than a hundred cents on
the dollar you know we got roiled when
as you pointed out it wasn't even
treatment even in the US as between
different classes of interests which is
to say a hundred a hundred hundred cents
on the dollar
but for the UAW because there was a
contract but you point out for the UAW
working guys they had renewed their
contract did we do their contract and
take concessions yeah double standard so
the the not surprisingly the financial
markets have resisted doing the kinds of
things that need to be done in the
beginning of our conversation we talked
about the risk of too-big-to-fail
institutions haven't done anything about
that and let's talk about some of that
because you talked about in the book the
importance of what had been a
glass-steagall type you explained need
to be updated but the idea of looking at
the size and also looking at firewalls
so that for instance commercial bank can
be gambling like an investment bank with
my savings and doesn't look like
Congress is looking either at size or at
the firewall that's right and and there
are other things that they haven't been
really adequately doing with incentive
pay one of the things that people are
very very concerned about incentives
paid leads to more risk-taking and
short-sighted behavior you know there
are some regulations that are trying to
move in that direction but but moving
very slowly not clear we're going to get
them through the part of the problem is
in regulation the devil is in the detail
so you can get something that looks
pretty pretty pretty good and then you
start reading inside so one of the
important things was the consumer
financial product safety commission that
many of these products that were being
sold to individuals we're not really
good for their interest they were good
for the banks because they generate a
lot of fees but not safe for consumption
it's not safe for consumption and you
know we we we look at toys we look at
food we eat but we are we say you can
buy these complex products that not even
the banks can understand and let alone
somebody who's the first-time homebuyer
so
very important I thought to have a some
kind of consumer financial product
safety commission it looks like we may
get one but it looks like 80 or 90
percent of the banks will be exempted
which is a real problem which is a real
problem so and they wanted to do just a
mild thing saying everybody who offers a
mortgage has to offer at least a plain
vanila mortgage no bells and whistles
just clear simple clear simple everybody
can understand they couldn't even get
that through so and on derivatives you
know one of the AIG associate you know
the derivatives would cost us a hundred
and eighty billion dollars you just
think of what we could do with a hundred
and eighty billion dollars what we are
doing again doesn't look like it's going
to be adequate we say we want more of
the derivatives to be traded on
exchanges but we will also allow the
over-the-counter non transparent non
fully disclosed derivatives but what are
the banks going to prefer where do they
make their money or they make their
money out oh they're not gonna make
money on on standardized products that
are trade and competitive competition
because in competent competitive markets
profits get squeezed to zero
they like the non transparency but how
do capital markets exercise discipline
if they don't know what the banks are
doing so the the problem is that here in
this key area again it doesn't appear as
if we're going to be doing enough and
even when we look like we're doing the
right thing if you look in the details
there eviscerating what the intent of
what what was needed well what are I
mean not number five necessary but like
what are the five things are the three
things are the three things that
Congress better do to be able to really
make sure we don't get into this pickle
again and also to make the economy the
financial part of the economy
work better for people you've mentioned
bankruptcy reform some easy very simple
reforms a payments and electronic
payment system not controlled by Visa
and MasterCard what would just be your 1
2 3 4 5 short set of things that they
need to do that they're not so too big
to fail too big to fail is clearly one
derivatives doing something about
derivatives clearly and other doing
something about incentive systems so
that you don't have these people
rewarded in ways to have excess risk
taking and short-sighted behavior you
need to do something about excess
leverage a whole variety of other ways
of risk taking you know they got to
thirty to one forty to one leverage what
does that mean it means that if the
value of the assets goes down by two
three four percent they're wiped out
what what happened to our real estate
assets they went down by thirty percent
they were wiped out multiple times so we
shouldn't have been surprised now the
thing about leverage is when things are
going up make a lot of money but from a
social point of view all the leverage
does is shifts risk from one place to
another
accepted the returns to the banks and
shifted the risk to the taxpayer we
can't allow that
and from effects yeah that's a really
big thing to fix so those are within the
financial sector the the most important
things to fix to prevent another crisis
but remember we want to do more than
prevent another crisis we want our
economy to start growing so we want to
try to make sure that we have a
financial system that actually does what
expose to do and that was that was a key
thing in the book talking about having
actually a clear vision of what you want
your financial system to do and what in
your view would that be and then what do
we need to do besides trying to avoid
the next crisis to actually make it work
moving forward well one of the points
I'm kind of raises is that incentives
matter incentives matter not just in the
bad way that they've mattered in the
past but if we got the right incentives
we get the right innovation the
innovation that we've had is
not been directed at improving the
ability of homeowners to manage the risk
of homeownership you know increasing the
stability of our mortgage market there
were ideas out there like the Danish
mortgage bonds but they they don't
generate the fees and they weren't
interested and those things so one of
the things that I think is important is
if we can get the incentives better
aligned between society and what the
private rewards are I think I have
enough confidence in the market maybe
I'm a optimistic here that they will be
innovative in ways that will improve the
well-being of our society one of the
things that we clearly have to do is to
try to encourage more lending to small
medium-sized enterprises and that means
that a variety of ways of doing that but
basically right now we encourage you
know we the way we gave the bailout
money if disproportionally went to the
big banks that make a lot of their money
not from lending but from trading so we
should have done things that encourage
that part now it's not too late
so the real economy actually gets the
financing yep so let's link if the Fed
is lending money to the banking system
let's say you can't use that money to
speculate in Brazil Brazil will be
happier and so will our our firms that
get the money be happier so this is a
win-win and they need it just to be able
to finance their operations exactly
we're people again to build demand
exactly so there are things like this
that we can do we've done things like
this and in other countries of donek so
this is not you know breaking new ideas
these are just using things that have
worked in other countries and at other
times and rather context in the United
States bring it to bear on our current
problems of increasing lending to small
and medium sized enterprises and the
other thing you mentioned I think is
very important is our having
electronic payment mechanism the current
system acts as a tax on every
transaction and a big tax you know
they're complaining about a small
financial service tax but they impose a
much larger tax a much larger tax on
every transaction every super whenever
you use the one of those debit cards
that they're imposing a big tax this is
going to be probably our last last
question is running of time but you
talked about the importance of gain the
financial system right as necessary and
not sufficient because the bigger
question is the broader economic system
and you talked about three challenges
that the world faces restoring demand
and full employment restructuring the
financial system and the restructuring
the US economy to deal with shifts in
the world's economic structure you
talked about hunting for new comparative
advantages and creating programs to aim
at that but in the mix of all of this
you talked about that challenge of the
balance between government and markets
and this perverse taboo in the u.s. to
actually do what's worked for us in the
past that period of growth when we had
regulated finance etc but else what a
lot of other countries our capitalist
market economies do and thinking of
those three big challenges I'm wondering
in closing what you think we're going to
see from the Obama administration going
forward and what you think ought to be
done well I think the Obama
administration has made a shift from the
Bush administration and recognizing
there is an important role for
government but the question is how do
you what that role is how big that role
ought to be if they all agreed that
there ought to be a role even the
financial sector agreed there aren't be
a role with bailing them out and giving
them a lot of money so everybody agrees
the government should do something if it
only to give banks money but I think
most of us think that it should have a
broader role and we talked in this
conversation a lot about a role in
preventing disasters if you're going to
if you're going to have to build big
hospitals
let's have
preventive care soap not so many people
go into the hospital but there's another
I think much more government you know
wood has been the the the most important
innovation of the 20th century and the
last part of the 20th century was the
internet who financed that governments
the private sector brought that to
market what I think Thanks so
interesting about that it is a kind of
private public sector partnership
couldn't've happen without the
government playing a critical role you
look at all the basic research on which
all the advances of science of
technology that we use most of that
basic research is supported by the
government there's a good theory good
reason why that's the case but the fact
is that you can't have the advances in
technology if you don't have advances in
science on which they rest therefore the
innovations and therefore the growth and
the employment of it all has to rest on
a foundation of government and that what
what I found so disturbing during the
Bush era was this constant bashing of
the government you know the government
doesn't do everything perfectly I mean
we and any of us who looked at what
happened during the Bush administration
have to agree that the government often
gets things very bad but it's also the
case the private sector often doesn't
get things perfectly no government no
democratic government probably has ever
wasted money outside of war on the scale
of our private sector in this crisis and
we should remember that so private
sectors fail governments fail we need to
have systems of checks and balances the
next part of the democratic process but
one of the concerns is that system of
checks and balances maybe getting
undermined and that goes back to what
Teddy Roosevelt said 100 years ago if we
allow some
economic forces to get too large they
will shape not only the economy but also
the politics antitrust law that he
advocated successfully was not so much
motivated by economic distortions and
that was an important aspect of it but
it was by how these could affect the
political process and I think as we look
at what has been happening in the last
year and what happened in the years
before the crisis we have to be
reexamining exactly that same question
and this book makes a very good
contribution to it as it lays out the
case and gives some very good ideas of
the role of government and what we need
to do going forward I thank you very
much for your time in this discussion